je me tiens au carrefour
il y a beaucoup de routes à prendre
je me tiens ici si silencieusement
j'ai peur d'une erreur
une route mène au paradis
une route mène à la douleur
une route mène à la liberté
ils se ressemblent tous
bien j'ai  parcouru de nombreuses routes
et elles n'étaient pas toutes bonnes
les insensées m'ont appris plus
que les sages ne pourraient jamais
une route mène au sacrifice
une route mène à la honte
une route mène à la liberté
et elles se ressemblent toutes
bien je me tiens à  le carrefour
je suis tellement emprisonné par mon doute
comme si en ne faisant rien
je pourrais trouver mon chemin
une route mène au paradis
une route mène à la douleur
une route mène à la liberté
mais je jure
qu'ils se ressemblent tous
voyager
il y a des virages
je n'ai pas pris
tant de mystères
je ne pouvais pas démêler
te quitter
était ma seule erreur
alors je suis debout à la croisée des chemins
je suis emprisonné par mon doute
comme si en ne faisant rien
je pouvais trouver mon
chemin  route mène au paradis
et une route mène  à la douleur
et une route mène à la liberté
mais je jure
qu'elles se ressemblent toutes
et il y a des routes que
je n'ai jamais parcourues
et les virages que
je n'ai pas pris
et les mystères que
je n'ai pas pu résoudre
en te laissant
ma seule erreur
je te quitterai
donc
toi